[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us
this morning that message has found a
home with basketball fanatics
cbs sunday morning correspondent lee
cowan introduces
us to a team creating hoops to connect
communities
and open a dialogue for social change
the venice beach basketball courts their
haven for pickup ballers
players come from everywhere to shoot
the venice vibe
until kovid shut it all down
that sent sparks flying for one player
who had suddenly lost his favorite
outlet
this is thin line between being safe and
sane
you know our motto is the game never
stops that's the way we connect
my favorite baseball baseball nick ansem
who goes by nico naysmith
founded the venice basketball league
but he's also an artist who grew up
outside paris
his twin passions found a home at the
end of a welding torch
deftly wielded by fellow artist and
friend lori powers
together they created what they call
survival hoops
we built about a hundred of them and we
were together every day
making hoops the hoop will go right in
here they're all made from reclaimed
items
chairs shoes even car bumpers
you just see a hoop in just about
everything i see a hoop and everything
you could put a few things on the ground
there and i could just immediately
make a hoop out of it
they've hung them in back alleys all
over venice
played them too downtown
but this is their real hoop dream an old
school bus
turned into a rolling court it was built
to bring venice street ball
to streets outside venice
when those streets filled up with people
protesting racism and police violence
nico thought his hoop bus should hit the
road too
like 2020 is cancelled i'm like wow but
i have this bus
and it's it's funded by the people it's
powered by the people
i'm like let's let's use what we created
together
to make change the hoop bus became a
magnet
protester even police were drawn to it
in unity did you ever
wonder what a guy who largely grew up in
france right how he he ended up being in
the middle of a black lives matter
protest
yeah no no i really don't think about it
the thing is like we're fighting for the
same cause we're fighting for justice
we're all one i'm just like doing what
what feels right
for the past month the hoop bus has been
on a cross-country road trip
stopping along the way to preach the
gospel of basketball and its ability
to bring strangers together it's a
mobile art gallery from top to bottom
pre-hester is one of the artists making
the track that's
him working on a painting on the roof
this
is his artwork too it was just amazing
to see how many people like
from every ethnicity every race
uh it was just phenomenal he too was
targeted by police who mistook him for
someone else when he was painting a
mural
on a wall a few years ago that makes
this pilgrimage
personal i was like george floyd
face down and a knee was to my back and
there was eight cops with guns drawn to
me
the youngest among us are most inspired
like 11 year old dash
corwin he made his own blm bucket i feel
like that it shows that
everybody can speak up even if you're a
kid
even if it's a small thing it still
helps a lot
now the hoop bus isn't going to end
racism but
nico naysmith hopes that it's a reminder
that victory comes
when everyone on the team is shooting
for the same goal
you see the back of the bus says vote
this is a beautiful country that has a
lot of opportunity but
if there's something you don't like like
take action on it for cbs this morning
i'm lee count in venice beach california
hello lee cowan i love everything about
that story everything me too
starting with the hoop buzz i know what
you're going to say and everyone's
shooting on the same goal yeah you know
i love that shooting for the same goal
that's right i mean that's what we need
in this country
shared reality and a shared goal i love
the black lives matter sign at the big
at the front and then the boat at the
back i love that he saw the opportunity
that he had this bus park there and he
could do something with it yeah
and a little boy dash who said it
doesn't matter your age you can all do
something
go dash